>> So we just gave you two concrete examples
of how you can improve the UX of your app.
>> Exactly. The Sign-In and Check Out buttons to replace
forms are a really good idea. But, I know that
I've actually ended up creating my own sign-in and check
out forms. And I spent a lot of time optimizing them.
>> Yeah, me too.
>> I'm sure you've done the same.
>> I, I've done the same thing. I've spent a lot of time trying to
design the perfect sign-in form, and I've tested
it with users and tried really hard to
optimize it.
>> Yeah. So the, the solution as we've presented them to you
are actually just Band-Aids. There's an underlying cause actually there is an
underlying problem which results in us. Coming up with these forms, and
really focusing on the forms rather
than focusing on the applications themselves.
>> If your first instinct was to optimize locally, and not to just
replace sign-in and check out with one of these solutions, what was your
thought process? Were you thinking too detailed? Were you thinking
too high level? Were you not thinking of the bigger picture?
Were you trying to reuse existing code? Or is it
something else? Or none of the above? Check all that apply.